WE ARE LEADING WITH THE
SUBJECTIVE ANALYSIS BUT THE
DATA ARE IN THIS REPORT AND
WORTH READING.
TOM FITTON GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> YOU'RE WELCOME.
TOM TOM THE FORMER ASSISTANT
DIRECTOR OF THE FBI JOINS US
TONIGHT.  MR. HOSKO, THANKS
FOR COMING ON.
I WANT TO READ TO YOU
EXCHANGE BETWEEN FBI
EMPLOYEES ON ELECTION NIGHT.
I CAN'T STOP CRYING SAYS
ONE.
I'M NUMB SAYS ANOTHER.
I'M SO STRESSED ABOUT WHAT I
COULD HAVE DONE DIFFERENTLY.
I THINK THE FBI'S INFLUENCE
MAY HAVE HAD AN EFFECT IN
THIS.
I DON'T KNOW, WE BROKE THE
MEANING THE MOMENTUM OF THE
HILLARY CLINTON CAMPAIGN.
HERE HAVE YOU UNNAMED FBI
EMPLOYEES LAMENTING THE FACT
THAT THEY COULDN'T HELP A
SPECIFIC POLITICAL CANDIDATE
BECOME PRESIDENT.
WHAT'S YOUR REACTION TO
THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, IT KIND OF
SICKENS ME, TUCKER.
I THINK THOSE EMPLOYEES,
THOSE MENTIONED IN THIS
REPORT HAVE FAILED THE
ORGANIZATION.
THEY HAVE FAILED OUT
EXPECTATION OF THE HIGHEST
DEGREE OF PROFESSIONALISM.
THEY HAVE LEFT THEIR BIASES
INTERSECT WITH AN
INVESTIGATION.
SO IT'S DEEPLY CONCERNING.
AND I THINK CHRISTOPHER WRAY
ACTION ON THAT.
>> Tucker: I'M CONFUSED
THOUGH AS TO WHY WE DON'T
HAVE A RIGHT TO KNOW WHO
THESE PEOPLE ARE AND WHAT
THEY ARE DOING NOW.
I MEAN, IF YOU WRITE IN AN
EMAIL AND APPARENTLY THIS IS
REAL, WE BROKE THE MOMENTUM,
WE HURT HILLARY.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE THAT
I'M HEART-BROKEN THAT SHE
LOST, DON'T I HAVE, AS A
CITIZEN, A RIGHT TO KNOW
WHAT YOU ARE DOING NOW?
WHO ARE YOU?
WHO WROTE THAT?
THESE ARE PUBLIC EMPLOYEES.
>> WELL, THEY ARE PUBLIC
EMPLOYEES.
THERE IS ALSO A PUBLIC
PROCESS.
THERE IS AN INTERNAL
DISCIPLINARY PROCESS.
IT SOUNDS AS THOUGH A NUMBER
OF EMPLOYEES HAVE BEEN
REFERRED TO THAT PROCESS.
AND SO, JUST LIKE THE
DIRECTOR SAYS IN HIS PRESS
CONFERENCE TODAY, IS HE
GOING TO HOLD OFF ON THAT
AND FOLLOW STANDING POLICY
UNTIL THOSE ISSUES ARE
RESOLVED.
NOW, WE MAY LEARN WHO THAT
IS LATER, QUITE CLEARLY WE
HAVE SEEN AND HEARD SOME OF
THE TEXT MESSAGES AND IM'S
BACK AND FORTH WITH STRZOK
AND PAGE.
THEY ARE VERY, VERY
CONCERNING.
AND, TRUST ME.
THE WORKFORCE IS HURT BY
THAT AND THEY ARE OFFENDED
BY IT.
>> Tucker: YEAH.
ALL THE OTHER PEOPLE
INVESTIGATED BY STRZOK AND
PAGE AND THE REST OF THESE
HAVE GROUNDS FOR REOPENING